Ever heard of the MBTI test? It's shorthand for Myers-Briggs Type Indicator.
First published in 1943, it still holds significance today and is used in many circumstances.
ranging from marital counseling and relationship compatibility, to career selection and personal development.
As lovers of psychology and personality types, we thought it would be fun to do a series on all sixteen types. Today we'll be talking about
INFJs otherwise known as 'The Advocate'.
Here are seven fun secrets revealed about INFJs
One: They're magical unicorns!
Okay, not in a literal sense,
But INFJs statistically have been reported as the rarest personality type. To be exact only one to two percent
of the world's population
identify as INFJs, with slightly more females than males. No wonder you're such mysterious creatures!
Two: They put the book in bookworm! As introverts, INFJs love to pass time with the good old reading hour.
They enjoy learning new things and have a broad range of interests, whether it's history,
Hogwarts or psychology. If you find that your INFJ hasn't gotten back to your text, they might just be visiting platform nine and three-quarters
Three: They know how to climb the social ladder.
Consider INFJs as the goats in society-
they know how to climb a mountain when they see one. Ambitious, knowledge- seeking and always open to self-improvement,
This type does what it takes to reach their goals. If they aren't careful, however, they may push themselves too hard!
Four: They see things and understand them. Think of Charlie from The Perks of Being a Wallflower, a classic
INFJ, or Holden Caulfield from The Catcher in the Rye. The minute they walk into a room they can absorb everyone's moods.
Five: They love a good puzzle!
INFJs might seem timid when you first meet them, but don't be fooled by their quiet demeanor.
They never shy away from a good challenge. Deep thinkers with rich inner lives,
INFJs enjoy problem-solving and reflecting on ethics.
Six: They're classy AF! This type likes the finer things in life
whether it means enjoying a good glass of wine or wearing a snazzy pair of Oxford's they strive for
sophistication. It's important for them to look and feel good. You'll catch them owning one or two quality items instead of five cheap ones.
Seven: They make routine on boring.
INFJs are masters at
organizing. From filing papers at work and color coding bookshelves, to planning the week ahead with those nifty bullet journals.
Meticulous about their details and regimens, you can always count on an INFJ to be prepared, punctual and persistent.
Are you an INFJ? Do you identify with these traits? Please share your thoughts below. We'll be exploring the rest of the personality types,
so stay tuned if we haven't covered yours yet.
Our comment of the video goes to VAD Day who wrote 'you forgot crushing on a fictional character'.
That's very true. Stick around till the end of every video to see if your comment made it to our next video.
Thanks for watching!